Henry Kissinger one of the most
controversial and Powerful figures in
American politics is dead Kissinger was
an American Diplomat and political
scientist he served as National Security
advisor and Secretary of State under two
presidents
and his career is full of a lot some
laudable achievements such as
normalizing relations with China but
also full of some actions that many call
war crimes
many of you watching are 100 positive
that Henry Kissinger is a war criminal
others might see Kissinger as a
brilliant leader who helped the U.S
navigate very uncertain times during the
Cold War I actually met Henry Kissinger
once I was working at a think tank in DC
where he was a counselor and trustee
and frankly I didn't glean much about
this guy's character in our little
meeting but since then we've gotten to
know him at least his career we've
studied him and his actions both the
good and the bad so today I want to look
at this man Henry Kissinger I want to
look at what he did and evaluate what we
can learn from this person who For
Better or Worse has played an
influential role in how American power
is wielded on the global stage on this
perhaps the most gentle and graceful
land in all of Asia President Nixon and
Mr Kissinger Unleashed 100
000 tons of bombs Henry Kissinger was
born on May 27 1923 in Germany when he
was a teenager his family left Germany
for the United States fleeing oppression
from the Nazis he went to Harvard and
later was drafted into the army during
World War II serving in a
counterintelligence role after the war
he returned to Harvard and pursued a PhD
in political science Kissinger made a
name for himself as a political theorist
and author he focused on the role of
nuclear weapons and this new geopolitics
that had emerged after World War II he
studied a political philosophy called
realpolitik which emphasizes how
countries gain power by reacting
practically to conflicts and situations
as opposed to based on ideology or
values but from my reading what made
Kissinger powerful was his ability to
connect with people to network in
Washington DC that was perhaps his
greatest asset and the thing that kept
him close to power This was later
exemplified by the fact that Kissinger
served under both Republican and
Democratic presidents you can start to
see Kissinger's real politique and
networking skills in full action well
before he ever stepped foot in the White
House according to this archived
document from Nixon's Chief of Staff
early in his career when he was working
for the Democratic president LBJ as an
advisor on Vietnam he cozied up to the
Democrats political opponent Richard
Nixon who was running for president
through cozies up to Nixon and conspires
to pass Nixon information about secret
Vietnam War peace talks happening in
Paris Nixon could potentially use this
information that he got from Kissinger
to prevent the peace talks from going
well which in turn would make the
Democrats look bad since they were the
ones in power and helped pave the way
for Nixon to win the presidency
[Music]
now there's a significant debate on
whether or not all of this sort of
backroom deal thing had any impact on
the peace talks but what I care about in
this little story is what it shows about
Henry Kissinger that he was willing to
go to these lengths to betray the
president he was working for and to Cozy
up to a candidate who he hated but
thought could potentially win the
presidency to pass on information that
could potentially compromise the peace
talks that might end the war in Vietnam
anyway the peace talks did indeed break
down the day before the presidential
election no less Nixon ended up winning
and Kissinger this political theorist
turned Power hungry networker had shown
that he was willing to sabotage peace
talks in the name of gaining favor in
the eyes of a powerful man Nixon
appointed Kissinger as his National
Security advisor giving him an
unprecedented level of control control
over what he could use the American
power machine to do on the global stage
all in the name of National Security
now listen most of us weren't alive at
this time so we don't really know what
this was like to live during the 60s and
70s when kind of everything was about
the Cold War and specifically Vietnam
[Music]
so now you have Henry Kissinger and
Richard Nixon overseeing this war it was
a war that was no closer to ending a war
that remember these two conspired to
lengthen so that together they could end
it and score Nixon political points and
this leads us to perhaps the most
infamous of Kissinger's sins
[Music]
there's a reason why Anthony Bourdain
said quote once you've been to Cambodia
you'll never stop wanting to beat Henry
Kissinger to death with your bare hands
that's because in March 1969 Kissinger
directed the U.S Air Force to fly over
Vietnam's neighbor Cambodia
a neutral third party and to drop bombs
everywhere President Nixon and Mr
Kissinger Unleashed 100
000 tons of bombs the equivalent of five
hiroshima's the bombing was their
personal decision illegally and secretly
they bombed Cambodia a neutral country
back to the Stone Age the goal was to
eliminate North Vietnamese supply lines
and strongholds that were in Cambodia
but the response was carpet bombing
carpet bombing is indiscriminate it has
unknown targets which means that
civilians usually get caught in the
crossfire
so now you have B-52s raining down hell
from the sky at all hours of the day
homes were reduced to Rubble entire
Villages were turned immediately into
refugees and what the record shows that
came out later is that all of this this
indiscriminate bombing is Slaughter from
above was approved by and then concealed
by Henry Kissinger
[Applause]
this map that you're looking at is not
some stylized representation of this
this is actual data we have the data of
every bomb hundreds of thousands of
bombs that were dropped on Cambodia
during this time
[Music]
all in all at least a hundred thousand
cambodians died in all of this 2 million
were made homeless and this is in a
country of only 7 million people in
total the US dropped two million 756
000 tons of bombs on Cambodia many of
these bombs went undetonated turning the
country into a Minefield of undetonated
explosives that still exist today and
perhaps more significantly contributing
to the destabilizing of this country
making way for a violent Communist party
to rise to power with a Vengeance
leading to a mass genocide all of this
happened in secret without the approval
of Congress it was Henry Kissinger this
one man wielding his deathly gotten
power to ruthlessly get what he wanted
at any cost as the endless war was near
its end peace negotiations kept breaking
down in response Kissinger sent another
round of brutal bombings around
Christmas 1972 in an effort to force the
North Vietnamese back to the negotiating
table
[Music]
and I'm not exaggerating here like
Kissinger literally said quote we bombed
the North Vietnamese into accepting our
concessions some historians argued that
the bombings had little effect on the
peace talks and instead only resulted in
more pain more death and more
destruction and yet this is where the
story takes an insane turn the next year
Henry Kissinger was given a Nobel Peace
Prize for brokering the ceasefire in
Vietnam an award given to him for ending
a war that didn't actually end an award
that his North Vietnamese counterpart
would decline two members of the Nobel
peace committee resigned in protest
because of this it is as if everyone at
the Olympic Stadium joined and carrying
an athlete on their shoulders in an
endless triumphal procession
without pausing to realize that in fact
he had won no gold medals at all and
Kissinger himself even felt weird about
this and offered to give the medal back
to the committee
okay this is one of the great parries of
the modern era that this ever happened
but it doesn't end here in Chile in 1970
Kissinger directed the CIA to
destabilize the country and seek to
overthrow its recently elected socialist
president the coup attempt failed here
but it eventually did lead to the
assassination of a Chilean General the
president was eventually overthrown and
replaced by this Chilean General who
would go on to kidnap murder and torture
his political opponents but because he
wasn't a communist Kissinger turned a
Blind Eye in fact one of the features of
Henry Kissinger during his time was
cozying up to dictators all around the
world all in the name of securing
America's place as the global superpower
he pledged his support for this
Indonesian military dictator as he was
invading East Timor using American
weapons we have this Declassified
document of the conversation between
Kissinger and this military dictator
Kissinger telling this military dictator
to move fast on his invasion and to not
be too obvious about the fact that
using U.S military weaponry and support
the dictator did move fast and soon was
Exterminating hundreds of thousands of
people Kissinger and his big powerful
apparatus standing by to watch what they
had sponsored while illegally bombing
Cambodia Kissinger also oversaw illegal
bombings in Laos he supported Pakistan
in their genocide against Bangladesh he
supported turkey as they invaded Cyprus
he helped kick off U.S dependence on
Saudi Arabia for oil in exchange for
selling them weapons a relationship that
we're still bound to today he supported
coups and death squads across Latin
America and the list goes on and on and
on I won't have it from him that he's
doing this against communism it's just
another of the constituents of the
gigantic lie that constitutes his
reputation he's a thug a crook a liar
and a pseudo-intellectual and a murderer
okay all of those things are factually
verifiable factually verified
I mean listen it was the Cold War like
again none of us can really capture what
that was like you had two superpowers
racing to see who could get more nuclear
weapons there was real fear here and
leaders had to make very difficult
decisions Defenders of Kissinger see all
of this behavior that I've listed as
just a leader living in the Cold War
having to do what it takes to avoid
nuclear conflict or a communist takeover
a vital Elder Statesman serving America
and making impossible decisions along
the way but the most vociferous critics
tend to see the opposite an evil genius
who was given the full arsenal of
American power which he then wielded to
achieve his Grand Vision of how the
world should look but when you look at
the Arc of Henry Kissinger's career
neither of these characterizations hold
he was not a master strategist or an
unparalleled genius in fact he's a guy
full of contradictions
he conspired to extend the Vietnam War
despite thinking that the war was
foolish he joined the Nixon White House
despite long maintaining that Richard
Nixon was not presidential material he
orchestrated these increased bombings of
Vietnam and Cambodia despite all
evidence indicating that the U.S could
not win this war a reminder that Henry
Kissinger grew up being bullied and
beaten up for being a Jew in Nazi
Germany and then he fled that brutality
to come to the United States where he
studied how power Works between
countries but also between people he
used those skills to navigate himself
into standing in the most powerful
places in the world next to the most
powerful people in the world the most
powerful military in the world at his
disposal and the permission to use it as
he saw fit Henry Kissinger knew what it
took to stay on top and what it took was
shifting alliances secret bombing
campaigns sabotaging peace talks
supporting dictators abroad and the list
goes on I guess the point here is that
Henry Kissinger's Master guiding
principle was to have no guiding
principle he infused that into his
leadership into his decisions leading to
the destruction of many lives around the
globe ripples that are still felt today
even if Henry Kissinger were still alive
I believe he would never face true
accountability for his actions he played
the game too well he's too liked by
powerful people on both sides of the
aisle But ultimately if we can learn
anything from this the death of Henry
Kissinger gives us an opportunity to
appreciate what can happen when too much
power is concentrated in the hands of
one man
thank you all for watching
um today's video is not sponsored we
actually made it many months ago and uh
published it today uh for obvious
reasons
um if you want to support the channel
and the journalism we do here you can go
to The Newsroom which is a place where
you can get behind the scenes of how we
do what we do here you can get access to
my scripts you can get music that you
can use on your videos if you're into
that and you can just support the hard
work we do here to tell stories that are
journalistically rigorous and fact
checked and all of those things that are
required um that is patreon.com Johnny
Harris that is The Newsroom and I
appreciate all of those who are
supporters and
um thank you all for being here and
subscribe if you're not already and I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]